ok dann können wir beginnen wir hatten
der letzten sitzung uns mit der wm
beschäftigt und zwar in der vorletzten
sitzung also die videos sind ganz
zentraler fehler so für unsere thematik
und bevor wir heute auf den sehr
anspruchsvollen text von immanuel kant
zu sprechen kommen wo sie sicherlich
einiges dran zu knabbern hatten wir
wollen wir noch mal kurz wiederholt und
uns noch mal kurz vergegenwärtigen was
die grundthesen von der youtube waren
und zwar deswegen weil immanuel kants
theorie der kausalität sein ihren
ursprung oder ihre anregungen sage ich
mal
gerade die teams kausalität theorie
verdammt sie kennen alle diesen
ausspruch das kann sagte david ulm hat
mich aus meinem dogmatische schlummer
erweckt und dogmatisch meint hier eben
bei kann immer unkritisch also naiv als
ob die kausalität in den dingen drin es
sei also als kommt einfach draußen
kausalität ist und das mit uns als
erkennt den subjekten gar nichts zu tun
hat und dann hatte der video neben sehr
scharfsinnig dafür argumentiert dass
kausalität nur was mit uns zu tun und
gar nichts mit den dingen also mit mit
mit dem erscheinen
also wir haben eben perzeption und das
können jetzt eben gerade noch mal ein
bisschen ein bisschen wiederholen was
sagt jetzt der youtube wo ist die
kausalität wie kommt sie ins spiel
welchen status hat es nicht mal ganz
kurz was sind die wenn sie jetzt
jemandem einen physiker einer physikerin
ergie zählen sollten was jetzt levit
juden so bedeuten dass über kausalität
gesagt was würden sie dann zahlen ja
bitte
[Musik]
ich war einfach aus
ja die frage ist also sie sagen richtig
also nach david hume kausalität eben
nicht objektiv gegeben wird etwas hinzu
jetzt ist nicht die frage noch wer was
hin zu tun also sie sagten jetzt der
verstand tut es hinzu da würde david
hughes sagen ihr nicht als würde kant
sagen das kann zeigt das aber david
lopez ist tut etwas hinzu ein vermögen
aber überlegen sie sich noch mal welches
vermögen tut das hinzu dass wir dann
wirklich von kausalität sprechen kann
ja genau also unsere genau unsere unsere
einbildungskraft könnte man vielleicht
auch sagen oder uns wie sie sagen
assoziations vermögen und dass wir dann
davon ausgehend dass auf ein ereignis
wenn es häufig von einem anderen
begleitet wurde das immer so sei sagt
david hume was ist das für ein vermögen
oder was für eine einstellung ist dass
das wir glauben dass eben jetzt habe ich
schon gesagt dass eben auch in zukunft
so sein wird das ist der glaube also
eine an beliefern jetzt nicht im
religiösen sinne ist und einfach eine
konditionierung eine gewohnheit könnte
man sagen kann kann man das gut lesen
hier geht das ja okay also dann ist ja
alles perfekt also wie gesagt kausalität
nachruhm kurz gesagt nicht in den dingen
von dingen spricht er ja auch nicht von
was spricht der stadt dessen was ist die
politologie
gegenständen object und was sind die
objekte jung eindrücke und perfektion
vorstellungen also sozusagen
bewusstseinszustände könnte man auch
sagen letztendlich empirisch gegebenes
was dann durch uns an was auch immer
unseren geist die frage ist ob so ein
geist überhaupt gibt jedenfalls
psychologische vermögen
weiterverarbeitet wird
kommen sie zur nächsten nämlich auf
jüngstes hin
die kandidaten können
so spricht also auch wenn
wie man das
in dem song
und auch immer
das ist nicht eben noch das heute
notwendigkeit ein guter hinweis genau
also man sagt die kausalität relation
ist eine also das verhältnis ist
notwendig auch wenn sie jetzt die frage
stellt ob man das dann logisch als
notwendige relation also eine notwendige
bedingung oder so darstellt aber es ist
ein zwang im spiel oder auch eine kraft
sagt der david jung sagt eine kraft und
von der kraft selbst haben wir gar keine
sinneswahrnehmung weil die kraft nämlich
allein vermögen ist eine disposition und
von vermögen können wir als solchen gar
keine erfahrung haben ja das ist ein
vermögen muss immer aktualisiert werden
um es wahrzunehmen aber ein vermögen als
solches schwierig wahrzunehmen also
diese kraft gute oder sie darauf
hinweisen es gibt also was was uns
zwingt was die wirkung zwingend macht
also wenn die ursache da ist dann muss
die wirkung zwingend erfolgen
ich hatte dass wir noch mal formuliert
wir hatten das ja ein bisschen logisch
re formuliert ich um hatte da so wir
hatten das so logische formalisierung
dann versucht sie hatten uns darauf
gestoßen
zwei möglichkeiten
das reicht eben diese wahrscheinlichkeit
zu dürfen er war keine einblicke gibt
und das andere ist eine notwendigkeit
aus die muster aus begriffen kommen weil
s keinen gibt der große rest musste
schon genau wie möglich erhalten
genau also das ist völlig richtig dass
wäre eine implikationen logisch gesehen
und jetzt sagt eben david hume wenn wir
ereignisse als ursachen klassifizieren
dann sehen wir ihnen nicht an oder in
dem rot eindruck oder was auch immer in
einem empirischen eindruck ist nicht
schon impliziert seine wirkung der
eindruck steht nur für sich um sagt
diese eindrücke weise nicht über sich
hinaus sie sind letztendlich
selbstgenügsam weiß nur auf sich selbst
zurück dass mit sich identisch wenn
überhaupt identisch jung sagt dass sie
verfließen ständig aber sie weiß nicht
auf etwas anderes hin in dem sinne dass
das andere ihre wirkung sei und sich
selbst die ursache dieses anderen das
können wir eben nicht erkennen die
ereignisse haben ereignisse oder
gegenstand was auch immer ein ereignis
selbst wird nur dann als eine ursache
eine wirkung eines anderen ereignisses
klassifiziert nach wenn wir sehr häufig
die erfahrung machen das ereignis derart
e1 ein ereignis der t2 mit sich führt
das dann die regularien aber es könnte
eben beim 1001 einmal ein ereignis der
a31 eintreten oder alt eine eigene art
e2 ausbleiben
das ist das problem der induktion wir
nehmen das an wir werden eine stimmung
eine gemütslage versetzt sagt jung
die uns erwarten lässt dass dann wieder
dasselbe ereignis folgt nach derselben
regula riet aber diese regel selbst die
setzen wir voraus und von der regel
selbst haben wir eigentlich keine
erkenntnisse
sagte für sie und wenn ich also jeden
fall sich keine 1000 versuchen behandeln
wollen
die ersten mal fällt das sicher auch
unter und es ist nicht statistisch
sondern messbar
es gibt also in der naturwissenschaft
ich weiß nicht ob man das bei der jugend
schon so voraussetzen kann den
verschiedensten bereichen auch in der
biologie brauchen nichts dazu zu sagen
gibt es also welchem land messmethoden
so dass es da nicht mehr von
wahrscheinlichkeiten geben der physiker
begann das versagen in deutschland ist
der unterschied nicht abgesichert und
bei den meisten ein sehr guter gegen ein
waren da haben wir gleich einen weiteren
jetzt noch im wasser außerhalb des klar
ist dass keiner abstreiten dass die zeit
des impressionismus
das ist hier hinten zeit es ist erst
behauptet aber eigentlich ist es schon
möglich
das ist noch so alt werden deswegen ist
natürlich sagt die theorie schulden das
ist dass man nicht sicher sein
rechtsanwalt dem buch es wird zeit ist
seit jahren also ich regierung also
wissen wer also in graz überwinden
ich habe ich alles problem das
diesseitige nötig ist das auf jeden fall
geben müssen da helfen
mein ganzes geld und mit
dieses land war immens man das auch mal
können wir bald mutter ist
wahrscheinlich nicht alle so
weil wir sagen die theorien lassen zu
haben da geht's lang mehrere meldung
erst eins dann hier und dann hierher
als diese natürlich emotionen
geschlossen wir haben mit einem
eigentlichen gegen konstantinos
konstante aufhebung des vorhabens ist
einfach gebrochen brechen und
es ist einfach auf evolution und
revolution bedeutet und da also zwei
bereiche
das ist kein wunder punkt
als die frage nach dem status der
naturgesetze sie sagen das ist doch klar
das sind konstanten und die sind
anerkannt generell und die gelten
objektiv und so weiter und sie sagen
dagegen nein naturgesetze werden
empirisch erschlossen werden
generalisiert und werden dann
vorausgesetzt postuliert oder hypos
passiert oder was auch immer
aber es könnte sein würden sie
vielleicht auch sagen dass es irgendwann
herausstellt dass wir eine noch
umfassendere theorie haben
nach der bislang gültige naturgesetze
modifiziert werden müssten es wäre
logisch möglich es wäre nicht käuflich
genau also in bestimmten bereichen in
besonders großen dimensionen besonders
kleinen dimensionen da kriegen wir die
ganzen naturgesetz und konstanten nicht
mehr zusammen kohärent und dann fehlt
uns eine übergreifende theorie und dann
könnte man ihm recht geben und sagen ja
man sieht es doch wenn man so lange
genug schaut und lagerung physik
betreibt werden wir irgendwann an den
punkt kommen wo wir neue in neue
dimensionen vorstoßen seien sie noch so
klein noch so groß wie eben diese
bislang als objektiv angenommenen
grundsätze nicht mehr geltung haben ist
eine reine empirische sache würde ich um
sei gleich was dazu
nur weil wir unser auch die größten
sogenannten goldstone danach nach der
physik werden
nach der physik wäre es ebenso zum
selben augenblick gelten sie eben in
bestimmten bereichen und bestimmten
bereich nicht mehr so gut
im selben augenblick je nach dimension
selben augenblick aber jetzt hatten sie
sich gemeldet
[Musik]
aber sie sagen natürlich wünschen sich
viele
dh jetzt auch von der geologischen
ausgangsbasis
da muss ich sagen das darf auch sagen
die man wahrscheinlich sei ich habe
natürlich als geschrieben
statistisch fast ergebnis können
und hier kommt natürlich
die erwartungshaltung dieser zwang diese
notwendigkeit die liegt in unserer
einigung in unserer disposition dasselbe
zu erwarten
wir werden durch unsere psychologie
letztendlich gezwungen
jetzt haben wir noch eine meldung gehabt
bin habe ich übersehen hat sie noch
sonst jemand nicht gut als ich glaube
dann hat das glaube ich noch mal uns gut
vergegenwärtigt also jung ist wenn man
ihn wird ein ganz ganz radikaler denke
ganz vatikan und hier gibt es eben zwei
und mindestens zwei lesarten von david
hume die eine lesart sagt das ist ein
skeptiker möchte alles kaputt machen
diese lesart gibt es übrigens auch von
immanuel kant den mann geht alles
zermahlen macht genannt hat also moses
mendelssohn hat in sogenannt und dann
gibt es eine andere lesart von clooney
sagt er ist einfach ein anthropologe der
um unsere gewohnheiten unsere
psychischen mechanismen beschreiben
möchte und der da nicht behaupten möchte
dass es keine kausalität gibt es gibt so
zumindest zwei videos eine stärkere
skeptische eine schwächere ich bevorzuge
ja dieses stärkere skeptische es gibt es
tische lesart weil man so die
interessantesten und theologischen
logischen ergebnisse bekommen und ob das
ich wirklich existiert ich hatte einen
kurzen exkurs letzten mal gemacht oder
auch dass ich nur ein bündel von
partitionen ist von dem wir nicht mal
das bündel das band erkennen können das
ist nach wie vor eine riesen debatte
also wir können mit der wii um argumente
gegen die karts vorbringen gegen den
karton moment also ich jung ist wenn man
ihn radikal ist ein unglaublich
aktueller und relevanter kritiker
unserer
natürlich kann man voraussetzen ob es so
was wie objekte der erfahrung überhaupt
gibt wird uns irgendwas wirklich gegeben
der fahrer das ist der mythos des
gegebenen von wilfried zellers hat der
hat es ein amerikanischer philosoph der
das kritisiert dass uns empirisch etwas
gegeben sei wie so ein grundbaustein
zellers würde das bestreiten aber
intuitiv leuchtet es erstmal okay also
zusammengefasst die diese notwendigkeit
der kausalität relation die liegt in uns
und sie liegt eben nicht in einem
rationalen vermögens und sie ist
eigentlich gut sie ist lebensweltlich
fundiert lebens wirklich heißt es
durchaus überlebensnotwendig aber es ist
jetzt auch nicht rational eigentlich wir
können ist rational nicht recht wird
aber warum sollte nicht nur 1001 einmal
ein anderes ereignis auftreten als das
was wir erwartet haben unter bestimmten
dimensionen dem wir uns begeben warum
sollte das nicht plötzlich anders sein
kann ich aus dem begriff heraus aus dem
ereignis heraus was ich wahrnehme nicht
schließen das ereignis hat das objekt
das ist in sich geschlossen das verweist
nicht über sich hinaus es hat keine
bezüge zu anderen und das kann man auch
in frage stellen könnte sagen wieso
sollte es nicht ereignis oder
sinneswahrnehmung geben die so sind dass
sie nur im kontext als solche überhaupt
erkannt werden können man könnte auch
sagen wenn wir jetzt sagen ein ereignis
oder objekten sind es darum spricht nur
für sich dann abstrahieren wir von dem
kontext dieses datums und verfälschen
könnte auch sagen sinneswahrnehmung
existieren als solche nur im verbund mit
anderen und die isolierung eines
einzelnen ereignisses ist eine
abstraktion das ist eine verfälschung
eine falsche beschreibung unserer
eigentlichen wahrnehmung dass würden zum
beispiel phänomenologie phänomene sind
sehr realistisch konstatiert
ausgerichtet und wir können sie gar
nicht als einzelne herauspicken wie es
macht natürlich eine grundvoraussetzung
gemacht und die er selbst nicht mehr
reflektiert aus für die und das da
müsste man ansetzen an diesem grund
baustein
ein erkenntnistheorie ok und jetzt
kommen wir zu diesen netten herren hier
weil sie heute von ihm wäre das ist es
ist sogar ein sehr authentisches ein
sehr authentisches gemälde oder eine
authentische zeichnung so sagen nämlich
wirklich aus
und da ist und wir lesen jetzt hier aus
der zweiten auflage der b auflage der
kritik der reinen vernunft die
sogenannte zweite analogie der erfahrung
jetzt haben wir hier ein riesenproblem
beim anerkannt während david jugend
intuitiv eingängig ist der schreibt so
verständlich und man sagt ihnen auch
nachher habe einen sehr guten stil und
sehr verständlichen stil dieses beim
anerkannt anders da verhält sich die
sache anders
immanuel kant hat eine sehr spezielle
begrifflichkeit und es ist eigentlich
sehr gewagt was wir jetzt hier tun dass
wir jetzt einfach so ein oder zwei
sitzungen markant lesen
andererseits sehen wir ja einen
fortgeschrittenen seminar dürfen uns ja
auch etwas zutrauen und ich gebe es ein
bisschen unterstützung indem ich jetzt
noch eben einmal den ich da wieder als
hintergrund als eine hintergrund folie
die letzten beiden sitzungen mit ihm
zusammen und erarbeitet habe von der wir
diese stelle hier an seine kritik der
reinen vernunft besser verstehen und zum
anderen gebe ich ihnen
ein paar leitfragen noch mit also
welchen unter logischen status haben
nach kant ursachen und wirkungen welche
ökologischen status hat nach kann die
kausalität relation oder auch welchen
logischen status hat sie immer
ontologisch dann wie kann nach kann die
objektivität der kausalität relation
gegründet werden vielleicht auch noch
die notwendigkeit diese konstellation
wie verhalten sich ursachen und
wirkungen zeitlich zueinander
das wäre das werden so die wichtigsten
fragen
die waren mal zu überlegen und dann will
ich noch ganz kurz als einführung
das ist eine wichtige frage wie es
objektivität einkauf sanität miteinander
zusammenhängen ich will dann aber noch
hier ein paar grundbegriffe noch kurz
erläutern
also allein wenn man mal hier nachts auf
den opa titel schaut grundsatz derzeit
folge nachdem gesetze der kausalität
also sagt es gibt ein gesetz hatte die
regierung bestritten dass er gesetzt
alles was existiert alles was sich
ereignet er eignet sich nach dem gesetz
der croisette
es gibt also nach immanuel kant nichts
was sich ereignet was nicht als solches
dem gesetz von ursache und wirkung
unterliegt was das gesetz von ursache
und wirkung alles was ist ist selbst die
wirkung eines vorhergehenden ereignisses
was seine ursache ist und es ist eben
aber auch zugleich die ursache wiederum
eines anderen also alles ist kausal
geschlossen das ist die kausale
geschlossenheit der welt man könnte auch
sagen der determinismus das prinzip des
determinismus alles was existiert ist
deswegen so weil es verursacht wurde
vielleicht nicht unmittelbar von etwas
anderen aber mittelbar tja
es ist nach kann schon objektiv aber das
ist eben verkannt objektivität ja also
schon aber das ist schon richtig also es
gibt da noch diesen begriff des dinges
an sich riesenproblem also das ding an
sich wäre das ding sagen das objekt was
noch mal unabhängig von unserer
subjektiven erkenntnis weiß existiert
und dann das kommen wir nicht ran
so kann man auch objektivität verstehen
aber so versteht kann nicht objektivität
kann versteht objektivität so dass es
wie sie richtig satten erkenntnis ist
die sich unsere subjektive vermögen
verdankt aber diese subjektiven vermögen
sind jetzt nicht bekannt so zu denken
wie bei david hume dass es bloß
psychologische mechanismen sind die bei
jedem vielleicht auch anders sein können
sondern kann spricht auch nicht von uns
als individuen und von uns als menschen
das ist auch noch ein wichtiger punkt
der video macht eine anthropologie
kritik
das ist also der tag der menschlichen
natur würde im handel kann nie sagen es
geht ihnen nicht um die menschliche
natur
es geht ihm um die subjektive struktur
unserer erkenntnis von vernünftigen
endlichen wesen kann spricht so gut wie
nie in seiner transzendentalen
philosophie also der kritik der reinen
vernunft von menschen so gut wie nie er
spricht von endlichen vernünftigen wesen
da können auch noch andere wiesen
darunter fallen außerirdische oder ich
weiß nicht was vielleicht sogar auch
affen würde kann wahrscheinlich das
gesagt hat nicht aber er fasst den
begriff extra so weit dass prinzipiell
auch andere endlich vernunft verstandes
wesen
darunter fallen und als er hatten sehr
viel grundsätzlicheren zugang zu dieser
thematik und kann sagt diese
grundausstattung die endlich vernünftig
gewesen haben insofern sie vernünftig
sind di ist eben überall gleich und sie
hat einen ganz anderen status ist
psychologisches sondern es ist was
vernünftiges ist also eine struktur
unserer rationalität und unser
sinnlichkeit sinnlichkeit meint jetzt
nach kant nicht irgendwie tierisches in
diesem sinne oder also sondern es meint
sinnlichkeit meint die bedingungen der
möglichkeit von erfahren kann fragt sich
wie können wir überhaupt eine führung
machen kann geht nicht davon aus dass
wir erfahrung machen und das macht eben
jung der region geht davon aus dass uns
erfahrungen gegeben sind und kann fragt
wie können uns denn überhaupt
erfahrungen geben werden was ist denn
dazu vorauszusetzen notwendig damit wir
erfahrungen machen können und ich
irgendwelche erfahrungen und und nicht
irgendwelche eindrücke wie bei der video
sondern ein zusammenhang von sinnvoll
geordneten erfahrung also wie ist der
sinnvolle zusammenhang der welt als
erfahrungs objekt möglich das fragt sich
kann und ein sinnvoller zusammenhang von
erfahrung ist eben nach kant unter
anderem ein in dem das gesetz der
kausalität geltung hat
wir können nur dann sinnvoll erfahrung
machen und kann überhaupt nur erfahrung
machen wenn wir das prinzip der
kausalität als objektiv ansetzen können
und nicht als etwas beliebiges an zehn
jahre
genau damit hängt das zusammen also raum
und zeit verhalten sich ganz ähnlich wie
die kausalität auch wenn sie jetzt nach
jungen nicht auf den verstand zu
beziehen sind sind auf die sinnlichkeit
aber sie sind eben eine reine
anschauungs form also es ist eine form
das ist eine form in der überhaupt
erfahrung stattfinden kann
also wir müssen uns so vorstellen damit
wir überhaupt erfahrung machen können
müssen nach kant bestimmte
rahmenbedingungen gegeben seien
innerhalb der überhaupt erfahrung
möglich
also einfach verschiedene rahmen raum
zeit und kausalität es sind alles drei
rahmen rahmenbedingungen die wir
voraussetzen müssen um überhaupt
sinnvoll einfach machen sie können alles
was sich ereignet ist nach kann
zumindest in der zeit im rauch
vielleicht nicht unbedingt wenn sie mir
überlegen dass die innere
sinneswahrnehmungen haben viele hre dann
ist die frage ob das jetzt im raum ist
es schwer zu sagen wo jetzt ein innerer
eindruck ist ist es im gehirn dort oder
dortmund also haben sie probleme her
aber in der zeit ist auf jeden fall
nämlich jetzt aber also alles ist
jedenfalls in der zeit deswegen ist zeit
noch ein bisschen genereller als der
raum als reine anschauungs form
dann gibt es eben den raum und dann gibt
es weitere rahmenbedingungen der
sinnvollen erfahrungsmöglichkeiten wie
kausalität aber auch dass überhaupt
etwas ein objekt sein kann eine substanz
sein kann dass ich sagen dieses ding hat
dieses ding verursacht das ist ja auch
eine sinnvolle beschreibung der der
wirklichkeit und auch diese tatsache
dass es hackern hier ist ein objekt das
hat diese eigenschaften das entnehme ich
nicht der unmittelbare sinneswahrnehmung
sondern das ist wieder so eine
rahmenbedingung
die in mir selbst enthalten ist aber
nicht als empirisches wesen sondern als
ein vernünftiges ähnliches wesen und
kanten diese theorie der
rahmenbedingungen der vernünftig endlich
ein wesen trans zentrale philosophie
transzendentalen meint eben die rahmung
die rahmung die nicht beliebig sind
überall gleich sind die auch ein
objektives notwendige geltung haben und
die eben unseren verstand littorin
unserer sinnlichkeit wie auch immer aber
in apricot gischen strukturen gegründet
sind als die licht apostel das heißt
nach der felsen vor der theorie aller
erfahrung sind dir und kannst ganze
transall philosophie ist eine theorie
des patriotischen also was muss vor der
erfahrung überhaupt schon stattgefunden
haben damit erfahrung möglich ist und er
fragt sich eben dann kann auch wenn wir
jetzt etwas voraussetzen was vor alle
erfahrungen ist kann es trotzdem
interessant sein das nennt kathan
synthetisch und ich kann natürlich sagen
ich weiß vor alle erfahrung weil sich
vieles zb weiß ich dass alle
junggesellen und verheiratet sind
dieser satz alle junggesellen
unverheiratet ist ein up rio risch
gewisser satz apriori scheißt vor alle
erfahren wenn ich die bedeutung dieser
worte keine junggeselle und so weiter
unverheiratet und weiß ich dass ein
junggeselle gut verheiratet ist und dass
der satz war ist aber diese erkenntnis
dieses dieses wahrheitsgehalt ist dieses
satzes die es uninteressant das ist ein
analytischer satz kann dann analysiere
ich nur ein begriff und bleibe im rahmen
des begriffs ich gehe nicht über den
begriff hinaus das ist das was auch der
video über die sinneseindrücke sagen
würde dass wir nie über die
sinneseindrücke hinauskommen und kann
sagte es gibt aber bestimmte formen des
wissens die apriori gewiss sind also vor
alle erfahrungen sind irgendwie dennoch
gehalts erweitern also synthetisch sind
die interessen
die bloß analysen von begriffen sind das
ist zb eben die erkenntnis von kausal
verhältnissen oder selbst macht kann
auch die mathematik die nach kant nichts
ab rio risches ist oder die geometrie
viele von ihnen würden wahrscheinlich
sagen dass wenn wir mathematik oder die
nichts nichts analytisches ist so muss
sagen also viele die meisten von ihnen
mich eingeschlossen wird erst mal sagen
dass geometrie zu betreiben oder oder
oder arithmetik dass das eine rein
analytische weise ist wir zick liedern
begriffe als wenn ich kann das
zurückführen vielleicht auf bestimmte
axiome die unmittelbar einleuchtend aber
es ist letztendlich eine analyse von
verhältnissen und kann würde sagen nein
geometrie zu betreiben oder arithmetik
ist nicht bloß eine begriffs analyse
sondern das ist eine konstruktion kann
sagt wenn ich arithmetik betreibe dann
begebe ich mich in die reine anschauungs
form derzeit also der reihe an chancen
derzeit die logische zeit sozusagen und
konstruiere in diese reihe anschauungs
form der zeit meine rechenoperation also
ich füge der drei etwas anderes hinzu
und das mache ich in der logischen form
der zeit und deswegen weil es in der
logischen form derzeit stattfindet was
selbst eine rahmenbedingung ist die
apriori mit gegeben ist ist es
synthetisch und nicht nur analytisch und
genauso in der geometrie hat kann der
geometrie konstruieren wir auch aber
nicht in der zeit sondern im raum der
rhein anschauungs form des raumes und
weil die reine angst anschauungs form
des raumes der sinnlichkeit entspringt
die also nichts begriffliches eigentlich
ist aber dennoch rein ist und nicht
apostel juli ist deswegen ist auch die
geometrie nach kant synthetisch und
zugleich das ist also
steile these viele würden kann da
widersprechen viele würden sagen
geometrie und arithmetik und und alle
logischen mathematischen operationen
sind rein analytisch das machen wir
begriffs analysen wir klären
verhältnisse kann wohl sagen nein
indem wir konstruieren ein dreieck
konstruieren und dann winkel ausrichten
machen wir das im rhein an chance form
des raumes und die rheiner und chance
und des raumes ist nichts begriffliches
ist nichts was analytisch wäre sondern
was der sinnlichkeit und springt aber
unsere reinen sinnlichkeit und er sagt
wir haben auch so was wie eine reine
raumvorstellung in uns die irgendwie
objektiv ist ein riesending jedenfalls
folgt eben kausalität oder ereignisse
die dem gesetzte kausalität folgen
erfolgen in der zeit die derzeit folge
und die zeit ist eben auch nichts was
außer uns geben ist sonst ist eine reine
an chance haben zu einer räumung die wir
eben mitbringen die in uns liegt aber
irgendwie doch dennoch nach kant
objektiv ist und jetzt hatte hier eben
diesen grundsatz und der lautet
folgendermaßen alle veränderungen
geschehen nachdem gesetze der
verknüpfung der ursache und wirkung
und das war auch die frage bei der
region wie müssen wir uns diese
verknüpfung und ursache wirkung
vorstellen nach jung gibt es keine
verknüpfung in den dingen selbst in den
objekten jedes objekt ist nur verzicht
existenz es hat keine objektive
verknüpfung die dinge die objekte weiß
nicht über sich hinaus und sie weisen
auch nicht zurück wie jetzt eine wirkung
auf seine ursache auf ihre ursache
zurückweisen können die wirkung hat zum
teil zurück und in der wirkung steckt
die information ich wurde bewirkt von
diese ursache zurückverweist
diese verweise gibt es noch nicht und
nach kant eigentlich auch nicht und
deswegen muss es etwas anderes sein was
ereignissen den status wirkung oder
ursache zu kommen lässt und das sind
eben gerade diese rahmungen das
abmischen rahmungen die
uns erfahrung erst ermöglichen das ist
so dieses grund settings sage ich mal
von david hume und von immanuel kant und
jetzt will ich noch ein bisschen was zur
terminologie sagen also das muss man
erst mal sagen was ist eine analogie
er sagte dass eine analogie der
erfahrung hier analogie zweite analogie
der erfahrung der frage was eine
analogie das analogien sind nach khans
technologie grundsätze oder regel des
verstandes die alle erfahrung voraus
gehen und diese erst möglich machen
also die gleichheit in den verhältnissen
von wahrnehmungen wie bei der wm
diese regularien story das ist die
analogie der regeln regula riet er
kannte hatte ein zitat kritik der
reinverlust baby ist immer die b auflage
also wir beziehen uns bei der zweiten
alu gi der erfahrung die wir jetzt
diskutieren auf die b auflage die b
auflage ist später erstehen
die auflage ist 1881 wer auflage
bisschen später
und da sagte eine analogie die erfahrung
wird also nur eine regel seien nach
welche aus wahrnehmungen einheit
erfahrung entspringen soll
es geht also um die einheit der
erfahrung haben die einheit erfahrung
und was uns geben die einheit der
erfahrung ermöglicht ist zum beispiel
das gesetz von causa liegt der
kausalität das ist alles ursache und
wirkung haben muss oder auch selbst
wiederum ist ist eine solche regel
nachdem wir die erfahrung besser
verstehen können oder überhaupt
sinnvolle erfahrungen machen können
das sagen hat das war die ursache
vergeben
und das wiederum von dem und ich kann
von allem die ursache finden und wieder
mit wirkung
das ist auch das prinzip der
naturforschung der physik dass ich immer
weiter nach ursachen forschen kann dass
es überhaupt möglich ist das verdanke
ich nach kant der analogie der erfahrung
regeln die in unseren verstand liegen
regelt es reine verstand das was auch
immer das jetzt ist also dass eine
analogie und es gibt noch ein begriff
die synthesis das ist die handlung das
mannigfaltige wieder technologie von
kanten das mannigfaltige zu einer
erkenntnis zu verknüpfen
und es ist ja auch kennen sie auch
synthetisch das ist künstlich eine
söhnen zusammen hieß es die setzung die
stellung die zusammenstellung etwas
verknüpft er sagt ich verstehe aber
unter synthesis in der allgemein ssten
bedeutung die handlung verschiedene
vorstellungen zueinander hinzu zu tun
und ihre mannigfaltigkeit in einer
erkenntnis zu begreifen kann sagt der
verstand selbst tut etwas
der verstand verknüpft zum beispiel
ursache mit wirkung sagt das ist das die
ursache und dass die wirkung ist das
verknüpfe ich zusammen einem urteil aber
die ursache von b und indem ich ein
solches urteil fälle verknüpfe ich zwei
ereignisse in der handlung des
verknüpfen
eine mannigfaltigkeit also eine vielheit
von ereignissen oder von was auch immer
zu einer erkenntnis und die erkenntnis
kann ich in einem urteil formulieren
aber die ursache von b das ist die
erkenntnis und die erkenntnis ist in
form eines urteils man könnte auch sagen
eine position als ein dass das die
ursache von bebra dass eine präposition
und dass das ist hängt eben mit einer
handlung zusammen mit der handlung dass
ich zwei ereignisse zusammen bringe
aufeinander beziehen und in einem
verhältnis bestimmen also jetzt endlich
ca ich fasse etwas zu sammeln kann sagt
jedes urteil hat er immer ein subjekt
und prädikat subjekt und prädikat
und er könnte auch sagen objekt und wie
die grammatikalische syntaktische
struktur von urteilen beschaffen ist so
funktioniert nach kant auch unser
verstand der verstand verknüpft
verschiedene sind taktische elemente
zueinander damit werden urteile fällen
können und die das urteil ist die
erkenntnis und dass wir überhaupt ein
solches urteil fällen können solche
erkenntnis machen können hängt mit
verschiedenen grundsätzen und
rahmenbedingungen zusammen hier zeitraum
qualität und so weiter so fort die wir
schon apriori voraussetzen müssen die
müssen wir schon als vorhanden denken
damit wir überhaupt sinnvoll erfahrung
machen können
damit ist jetzt natürlich noch nicht
gesagt dass diese rahmenbedingung auch
wirklich existieren
das ist jetzt erst mal noch ein anderes
team das macht dann kann in der trans
zentralen detektion da versucht kannte
es ist also ein ganz bekanntes kapitel
der versuch kann dann die objektive
geltung dieser ganzen kategorien des
verstandes zu begründen interessiert uns
jetzt aber nicht wir gehen jetzt einfach
mal nur auf dieser ebene was müssen wir
voraussetzen was muss angenommen werden
in dieser rahmenbedingungen damit eine
einheitliche erfahrung überhaupt möglich
ist dass wir nicht dieses problem
bekommen wie david hume dass wir nur von
einzelereignissen sprechen können die
nicht über sich hinauswachsen und wieder
letztendlich total verzweifelt sind in
dieser mannigfaltigkeit wie kann zeigt
die aber da nicht eine einheit innerlich
aufweist das ist das problem
da gibt es eine abrechnung
das ist eine erfassung zusammenfassung
der verschiedenen eindrücke zu einer
vorstellung
das ist also ganz ähnlich wie eine
synthese hat er wieder eine
ein zitat prävention das ist aufnahme in
die synthesis der einbildungskraft also
wenn ich es recht verstehen muss ich
erst der prävention haben und dann kann
ich die synthesis machen
erst mal müssen die vorstellungen als
müssen die verschiedenen eindrücke zu
einer vorstellung geordnet werden das
ist wie bei der video der wm ist
sozusagen nur auf der ebene der
prävention
wir haben eben verschiedene eindrücke
und wir haben dann eine vorstellung
davon wo bei der ermittlung nicht so
weit gehen zu sagen dass wir wenn wir
eine vorstellung von eindrücken haben
dass wir dann irgendwie ein höherer
einheit haben anhören einheits grad sagt
jung natürlich nicht wir haben jetzt
endlich genau die schwachen abbilder die
genauen mährisch identisch sind mit den
eindrücken den starken eindrücken
bekannt würde sagen nein in der
prävention da verknüpfen wir schon auf
seine pauschalen da bieten wir eine
einheit diese verschiedenen eindrücken
aber eben nur in der vorstellung und
nicht in der erkenntnis dass ist also
noch nicht begrifflich und dann wenn wir
also eine einheit der vorstellung haben
der verschiedenen eindrücke also jetzt
endlich es geht darum dass wir das
abspeichern
wir haben jetzt verschiedene eindrücke
gehabt und nicht speichern wie die
eindrücke ab überlegen sie mal wenn sie
jetzt was sagen das ist die ursache dass
die wirkung wenn sie das nur machen
könnten auf basis der instanzen
wahrnehmung dann wäre ja schon wieder
die ursache weg wäre schon wieder
verschwunden
ich habe mir da nur die wirkung und dann
kommt schon wieder das nächste usw
und dass sie eben beide ursache und
wirkung zur gleichen zeit präsent haben
und mit aufeinander beziehen können das
ist die prävention
das ist die vorstellung das heißt ihnen
werden die verfallenen eindrücke wieder
gegenwärtig
und zwar in einem zusammen
der vorstellung damit ist aber jetzt
noch nicht direkt irgendwas
begriffliches darüber ausgesagt oder
eine erkenntnis gemacht ist ja nun
wahrnehmungs urteil gibt ja noch ein
anerkenntnisurteil und das erkenntnis
urteil das ist dann wenn ich kann
richtig richtig verstehe diese sind es
ist also von dem er davor gesprochen hat
da werden dann die verschiedenen
vorstellungen aufeinander bezogen und
begrifflich gefasst und dann wird ein
erkenntnis daraus als die ursache von b
das heißt da kommt dann die ganzen
kategorien noch ins spiel noch weitere
rahmungen die unsere erfahrung erst
möglich machen also man könnte sagen so
zu sagen wir haben hier verschiedene
umrahmungen erstmal zeit den raum und
damit auch mal sei das jetzt hier
kausalität und wenn wir jetzt diese
prävention machen dann sind wir in den
rahmenbedingungen von raum und zeit
gehabt vielleicht wird sein
und wenn wir zur synthesis kommen dann
gehen wir noch einen weiteren rahmen
dazu wir bewegen uns sagen immer mehr in
die mitte des zentrums und dann kommt
eben so was wie eine kategorie der
kausalität hinzu das ist auch etwas rein
ab rio risch ist das gehört uns
inflation zum verstand
das ist nichts was ab osteologie ist was
empirische sein
so könnte man das sagen also wir
verknüpfen immer mehr wir verdichten
immer mehr die erfahrung indem wir
rahmenbedingungen ab anwenden dass sie
in rahmen also rahmen letztendlich in
die einheit bilden
und irgendwann haben wir so viele rahmen
für uns letztendlich um diese basalen
rudimentären eindrücke herum gewickelt
sage jetzt mal dass sie uns so
erscheinen wir haben nicht nur sie rom
gewidmet haben wir ein bisschen
verknüpft
wir haben sie gerahmt letztendlich dass
sie uns letztendlich im handhabbar sind
in form einer erkenntnis eines
begrifflichen urteils zu missversteht
immer mehr rahmungen drum herum machen
und die prävention ist eben wenn ich es
recht zäh nötig sind sind seien grob
gesagt nur die ersten beiden rahmen als
raum zeit und dann muss noch eine
zusätzliche rahmen zu das ist
und die kausalität und noch weitere
kategorien also es geht immer sie müssen
ist wie so eine schachtel ung von von
rahmen vorstellen und am ende bleibt
eben nur noch hier so nix übrig das ist
dann so der letzte rest der nur
empirisch gegeben ist danach kann bleibt
eigentlich fast nichts mehr empirisch
übrig fast nichts mehr apostolisches wir
bringen so viel ab rio risches mit dass
am ende nur noch ein kleiner punkt da
bleibt und der wirt oder 2 1 wegen und
der wird dann gerahmt dass wir überhaupt
hier die zwei erkennen können dass sie
vielleicht zeitlich auseinander liegen
das verdanken wir wieder hier der
anschauen der zeit sehen also es immer
es gibt überhaupt irgendwas empirisch
machen zu können sagt da muss schon
vieles davor der fall gewesen sei damit
ich sagen kann dass ein ex war nach dem
ixs brauchen wir schon dass hier das
impliziert letztendlich diese rheine
anstoß habe zeit dass ich sagen kann das
war die ursache von dem impliziert
diesen kasten und das so sagen kann
das war hier das war dort im pc diesen
kasten und das nennt man auch
transzendentale analyse also die analyse
der voraussetzung die überhaupt schon
eingegangen sein müssen damit ich so und
so sprechen kann
das ist eigentlich das verdienst von
kannte sagt david jung also damit du das
sagen kannst musst du setzt du implizit
schon das voraus das machst du aber
nicht explizit und ich kannte sagt er
jetzt wird er sagen ich mach euch jetzt
mal alles explizit was ihr begrifflich
schon ins spiel bringen müsst um
überhaupt eine sinnvolle einheit macht
einheits erfahrungen machen zu können
und das sind diese ganzen rahmen
damit ist jetzt natürlich noch nicht
gesagt dass diese rahmen tatsächlich
existieren und das ist natürlich ein
riesen problem wie kann es sein kann
dass sie wirklich jeder sagt sie müssten
vorausgesetzt werden um sinnvoll
erfahrung machen zu können
anderer punkt wäre könnten wir nicht
auch andere rahmens verhältnisse
voraussetzen um dieselbe erfahrung
genauso machen zu können
wieso muss es genau diese rahmung sein
wie so könnte es nicht eine andere
rahmung sein
das sagt jetzt hier noch nicht wir
wollen jetzt erstmal nur in unter diesem
gesichtspunkt sehen was wir für sinnvoll
voraussetzen müssen um das
machen zu können und wenn wir dann sagen
können das ist einleuchtend also wenn
wir das an sitzen das dass das dann
können wir das erklären dann ist für
unsere zwecke erstmal genug getan wir
wollen nicht noch in diesem seminar
zeigen dass sie auch wirklich objektiv
geld geltung haben und dass nur diese
rahmens verhältnisse hier angenommen
werden können und andere nicht zum
beispiel würde hegel georg wilhelm
friedrich hegel wird das bestreiten
erheben würde sagt eine ist nicht dieser
rahmen ist eine andere und schelling
friedrich wilhelm joseph schelling
nachdem diese schellingstraße hier 100
meter entfernung benannt ist der etat
liegt auch sagen die bekannt du bist
schlafen guten weg aber ein bisschen
muss ich dir hier noch widersprechen und
so war es gibt dann immer dieses gefüge
der apulischen bedingungen und rahmungen
das ändert sich aber alle deutschen
idealisten zu heißen die sind sich darin
einig dass es rahmungen und gefüge sein
müssen die wir vorher schon annehmen wie
dieses gefühl gedanke im einzelnen genau
gestaltet ist geordnet ist das ist dann
noch eine frage der unterschiedlichen
akzentsetzungen und es gibt eben jetzt
auch in der neueren debatte gerade in
den usa es gibt ein paar orte chicago
ist ein ort pittsburgh ist ein ort aber
dann noch freie leipzig in deutschland
ist ein ort und münchen auch so ein
bisschen die auch so ein schwerpunkt in
der münchner philosophie das sind solche
orte wo man hier in dieser tradition von
kant und in deutschland ist noch steht
also wo man versucht da diese
akribischen bedingungen die
voraussetzung die mich einfach nur
willkürlich oder subjektiv sind
individuell sind die im objektiven
anspruch erheben diese voraussetzung zu
expliziten und in ihrer logik zu
entfalten als wie verhält sich jetzt
diese rahmenbedingungen zu dir oder wie
verhalten sich weitere rahmen
es ist ja mit dieser rahmenbedingungen
der kausalitäten und nicht getan nach
immanuel kant sondern kommt ja noch die
substantially tät also dass ich sagen
kann das ist ein tisch und er hat diese
eigenschaft diese farbe weiß das ist
wiederum im rahmen der noch mit dazu
kommen muss nach kant und so gibt es
auch viele andere haben sind jetzt
endlich lauter rahmen und verlaute
rahmen bleibt dann am ende nur noch so
ein ganz minimaler punkt übrig der fast
ausnahmslos und eigentlich letztendlich
völlig abstrakt einig ist und das ist
der punkt der sinneserfahrung den wir
machen also der letzte rest letztendlich
der nicht a priori ist es kommt nach
kant wir brauchen nach kant ein letztes
moment von nicht a priori also von
letztendlich apostolischen daten
es muss doch irgendwas gegeben sein aber
das was gegeben ist so minimal
das ist eigentlich kaum ins gewicht
fällt sage jetzt mal ein bisschen weiter
expliziert und da liegt natürlich der
schritt gleich nicht weit ist der
schritt nicht weiß sagt ach wir
analysieren einfach weiter und finden
dann weitere rahmen immer weiter rahmen
des am ende dieser punkt nicht mehr
nötig ist also das dann dieser versuch
bei hegel und bei schelling sagen wir
brauchen die anschauen
wir brauchen die sinneserfahrung gar
nicht wir können alles selbst die
wirklichkeit selbst die erfahrung sage
jetzt mal bis zugespitzt können wir aus
und apriori struktur erklären wir
brauchen gar nichts mehr was von außen
gegeben ist wir können alles aus der
vernunft heraus würde jedenfalls tagen
erklären
und das ist natürlich eine starke teams
mit
da ist der guglmänner es muss also gab
er würde nichts sagen auch kant würde
nicht sagen dass es ein konstruktivismus
ist so kann man es lesen aber diese
philosophen in dieser tradition der
deutsche journalisten würden eben das
nicht sagen sie würden sagen wir machen
eine analyse unsere erfahrung und wir
finden dass wir überhaupt erfahrung
machen zu können bestimmte
grundvoraussetzungen annehmen müssen und
dass wir diese nicht nur annehmen müssen
sondern dass die auch objektiv gültig
sind und markus gaab gehen würde
letztendlich und der tradition von kant
durchaus stehen das in der trans
zentrale philosophie aber er versteht
die erkenntnis im sinne von sin feldern
er spricht einer sinn feld und theologie
als er spricht auch von rahmen
entspricht den feldern das was bei kann
letztendlich apriori anschauungs formen
sind oder kategorien sind bei markus
capri sennfelder aber im prinzip ist es
genau dasselbe wie bekannt ist als auch
die trans zentrale philosophie bei
mangel kann er bei markus gehabt reden
kann ich ihnen eine eigene publikation
empfehlen wo ich beteiligt war es gab
ein jahrbuch kontroverse vom
philosophischen jahrbuch da wurde es
seine theorie des neutralen oder neuen
realismus kritisch diskutieren also wenn
sie das interessiert kann ich ihnen
diese debatte zugänglich machen also
markus gabel ist eben ein prominenter
euro für den meinte ich jetzt gar nichts
ist er als ich mich auf leipzig und auf
andere orte bezugs und es gibt noch eine
dezidierte hre forschung der neueren
philosophie die sich speziell auf kant
richtet und die finden sie eben vor
allem in leipzig und in pittsburgh und
in chicago
da gehört markus gab gar nicht so sehr
dazu in diese richtung wollte nur sagen
das ist nicht schnee von gestern sind
das ist eben noch durchaus aktuell das
wird auch noch heutzutage
betrieben mit guten gründen der vorteil
ist eben der dass man sagen kann
erfahrung ist nichts was uns von außen
jetzt nur gegeben ist sondern wir selbst
sind daran beteiligt das kann man jetzt
konstruktivistischen länder aber das
würden die deutschen realisten eben
nichts sagen sie würden sagen das was
die anderen konstruktivismus nennen das
nennen wir nur objektivität
wir versuchen nur die objektivität der
erfahrung zu demonstrieren und die
implikationen die voraussetzungen
explizit zu machen die wir immer schon
eingehen wenn wir urteile fällen wenn
wir sagen dieser steines droht diese
tisch ist weiß wir machen nur die
voraussetzung explizit und wir zeigen
ihre objektive geltung auf ne also kann
man selber machen im thema mit dem
gebiet erkenntnistheorie wahrnehmung sec
wahrnehmungs theorie was ist überhaupt
eine wahrnehmung das ist eine spannende
frage
ok also das ist eine attraktion und
jetzt können wir wenn sie nicht noch
weitere fragen haben zu dieser thematik
können wir eigentlich schon mal
einsteigen ich habe ziehe eine
textversion genommen aus einer cd
ethischen sehr empfehlen kann die heißt
kant im kontext
die kostet 250 euro wenn sie mehr gibt
es verschiedene versionen im umfang an
deem kontext von carsten hoefer software
heißt der hersteller
und wenn sie das studierende studierende
sind kriegen sie da auch ein rabatt
können sie das im internet bestellen ich
kann warum schicken ich habe damit sehr
gute erfahrung gemacht weil sie einfach
hier
den bestmöglichen text originalgetreu
auf eine sehr komfortable weise mit
einer cd oder mit nur download version
bekommen ich habe da also fand dieser
serie ich habe von jeglicher von celli
und ich kann deswegen immer sehr gut
alles durch suche nach bestimmten
begriffen
das ist jetzt eben aus dieser version
übernommen und hier sehen sie ja ist die
schreibweise original als sukzessive mit
c zum beispiel deswegen nicht oder
insgesamt mit 2 mm also nicht wundern
dass ist die ursprüngliche schreibweise
[Musik]
da ist also wirklich nur der text also
es gibt vielleicht noch ein bisschen was
drum herum es gibt noch ein bisschen
eine bibliographie ist noch dabei
vielleicht auch noch ein kant lexikon
aber dieses kant lexikon finden sie
kostenlos im internet das ist dann aus
dem anfang des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts
ist immer noch aktuell da hat sich nicht
viel geändert
aber letztendlich brauchen sich auch
nicht kaufen weil sie kriegen den ganzen
kantischen text in dieser version auch
online kostenlos zb von diesem kant
korporal bonn kann ich in den linken
unterstützen
kriegen sie auch alles online brauchen
sie nicht kaufen würden wenn sie finden
zu kant unheimlich viel online kostenlos
jedenfalls dass es dieser cd entnommen
ich hab halt sehr gerne komfortable
suche und exportiere funktion sie können
zum beispiel das dann auch zur hebung
und seine pdf format ihren das mache ich
eben immer sehr gerne aber es brauchen
sie natürlich nicht natürlich kann man
auch noch nach wie vor die ganz
gewöhnliche meiner ausgabe die ich schon
entdeckt habe nehmen oder eine suhrkamp
ausgabe die wahrscheinlich hier liegt
wie ich auf einem blick feststellen kann
ich rate eben dazu eine textausgabe zu
nehmen die diese partie nie rungen hat
also b das ist die b auflage und dann
ist es die 233 also dass ich da eine
gute platzierung haben da sie eben
sauber zitieren können
das ist so wichtig in der in dieser
grünen eine ausgabe von meiner verlag
ist eben hinten noch so ein glossar drin
das ist sehr sehr hilfreich wenn sie mal
ganz hinten schauen da gibt es dann noch
so ein paar seiten wo diese wichtigsten
begriffe wie jetzt zum beispiel
prävention oder synthesis wo die
erläutert werden und zwar wo immer auch
dann bezug genommen wird auf die
jeweiligen passagen wo diese begriffe
verwendet werden da stehen zb 233 können
sie da einmal
das finde ich sehr hilfreich in der
meine ausgaben ok also jetzt geht es
hier los kann sagt dass alle
erscheinungen derzeit folge insgesamt
nur veränderungen
das ist ein sukzessives sein und
nichtsein der bestimmung der substanz
sein
jeder gehört wirklich dass sein der
substanz selbst welches aufs nichts
seite verfolgt oder das nicht seine
selben welches auf star sein folgt
anderen worden dass das entstehen oder
vergehen der substanz selbst nicht
stattfinde hat der vorige grundsatz da
getan
dieser hätte auch so ausgedrückt werden
können aller wechsel sukzession der
erscheinung ist nur veränderung denn
entstehen oder vergehen der substanz
sind keine veränderung derselben weil
der begriff der veränderung eben
dasselbe subjekt mit zwei
entgegengesetzten bestimmungen als
existieren mithin als beharren
voraussetzt sollte inters 1 also was ist
jetzt hier eine veränderung was
verändert sich an einer substanz wenn
sie sich verändern
ja wichtig den er aber noch davor ja ja
also die substanz genau alle die
eigenschaft letztendlich also die
substanz zb eigenschaften akzidenz ist
natürlich nach aristoteles auch die lage
wo befindet sich die substanz zu 50
dauert ein raum zeit und dann befindet
sich dort ein raub zeit das ist eine
akzidenz das ändert an der substanz
nicht die substanz ist immer noch
dieselbe
sie hat eine andere situation oder die
substanz hat jetzt wirklich mal eine
weiße farbe der tisch oder ich mache
jetzt hier mit dem edding wie was drauf
dann hat sich die die des aktions die
eigenschaften ändert die
erscheinungsweise aber immer noch
dasselbe tisch mit irgendwas drauf mal
als er sagt es ist wenn sich etwas
verändert ändert sich nicht ist nicht so
dass die substanz nicht ist und dann
wieder ist sondern sind erscheinungen
aber an der an der substanz und nicht
ein vergehen oder entstehen der substanz
selbst wir müssen die substanz immer
voraussetzt um wechsel erkennen zu
können und das ist schon wieder der neue
rahmenbedingungen hier
damit ich veränderungen wahrnehmen kann
muss ich mit substanz voraussetzen die
konstant bleibt es wieder so eine
implikation ich aber wieder wieder so
ein kästchen haben nämlich kausalität
und dann setzt es wieder substanz voraus
wie auch immer die frage ist ob ihr's
die rahmung der kausalität kommt und
dann die rahmung der substanz oder erste
warnung der substanz sind dann die der
kausalität darüber kann man diskutieren
aber jedenfalls müssen wir damit einen
wechsel stattfinden kann etwas
voraussetzen dass sich ändern kann an
dem der wechsel auftreten können wieder
so eine rahmenbedingung david jung
musste zugeben dass wir selbst keine
substanz wahrnehmen können wir nehmen
immer nur andere positionen waren aber
nehmen keine substanz war die beharrt im
wechsel
deswegen konnte ich um streng genommen
auch nicht sagen dass ein ding mit sich
identisch bleibt konnte er nicht sagen
sagt auch wir müssen es glauben endlich
aber wir gehen das aus dem raum heraus
und warum sollte es jetzt sehr sehr
witzig zahlen wir sehen eben wieder eine
ähnliche vielleicht an auch nur von
position aber diese identität die
numerische entität können wir auf einer
basis von perfektion nicht begründen
müssen so was wie eine unveränderliche
substanz voraus es ist wieder mehr
rahmenbedingungen jetzt ist noch eine
interessante sache bei dem nächsten
zitat spricht denn auch von gegenteil
also er spricht denn er verspricht
spricht von einem sukzessiven sein und
nichtsein der bestimmungen der substanz
also die substanz hat zum zeitpunkt 1
die bestimmung und zum zeitpunkt t2
irgendwie die bestimmung nun also nicht
dass leute jetzt erstmal nicht so ganz
einfach können nur sagen hat einfach bc2
sbb muss nicht nur sein das muss nicht
das gegenteil sein aber kann denkt denkt
ist ja wohl ganz abstrakt sie hat
irgendwas und im zweiten
zeitpunkt ganz ab sagt hat sich das
nicht mehr einfach nur sein oder
nichtsein
sie hat jetzt die farbe weiß und im
nächsten oder sie hat diese farbe wie
jetzt und jetzt mache ich was drauf das
hat sich das nicht mehr hat sich was
verändert und das ist ganz abstrakt
gesehen erst mal nur dass eben nicht
mehr das okay das ist jetzt also die
substanz jetzt sagt er folgendes ich
nehme wahr dass erscheinungen
aufeinanderfolgen das ist das einen
zustand der dinge zu einer zeit ist
jetzt kommt es im gegenteil im vorigen
zustande war deswegen ist das jetzt das
gegenteil wenn ich es recht sind ich
verknüpfe also eigentlich zwei
wahrnehmungen in der zeit bis zur
knüpfung kein werk des bloßen sinnes und
der anschauen so weit ist der wird ihm
recht zu geben sollen hier das produkt
eines synthetischen vermögens der
einbildungskraft die den inneren sinn in
ansehung des zeit verhältnisses bestimmt
diese kann aber gedachte zwei zustände
auf zweierlei art verbinden so dass der
eine oder der andere in der zeit voraus
gehen denn die zeit kann an sich selbst
nicht wahrgenommen und in beziehung auf
sie gleichsam empirisch was vorher gehe
und was folge am objekt bestimmt werden
also das objekt selbst hat keine
eigenschaften zeit sind es existiert
jederzeit es kann nur wahrgenommen
werden wenn es in der zeit ist also
wieder den rahmen
die rahmen ich bin mir also nur bewusst
dass meine imagination eines vorher das
andere nach ersetze nicht das im objekte
der eine zustand vor dem anderen vorher
gehe
oder mit anderen worten es bleibt durch
die bloße wahrnehmung dass objektive
verhältnis zueinander folgen erscheinen
unbestimmt damit dieses nun als bestimmt
erkannt werden muss das verhältnis
zwischen den beiden zuständen zugedacht
werden dass dadurch als notwendig
bestimmt wird welche derselben vorher
nachher und nicht umgekehrt müsse
gesetzt werde
es ist also diese notwendigkeit die
jetzt ins spiel kommt und da würde jetzt
immanuel kant sang auch diese
notwendigkeit in der abfolge der
erscheinungen die es selbst nichts was
den erscheinungen selbst anhaftet sind
damit ich was von notwendigkeit erkennen
kann muss ich wieder eine rahmung
vornehm ist die rahmung der kausalität
dieses gesetz ist das alles was sich
ereignet eben dem prinzip von ursachen
wirkungen folgt haben sie da noch nie
bemerken dazu da ist etwas nicht ganz
klar
das ist jetzt sehr schwer formuliert das
muss man schon sagen ja das ist ja
also die zeit muss vorausgesetzt werden
damit kausalität möglich ist zu würdigen
kausalität nur in der zeit
man kann sich natürlich fragen gibt es
nicht auch eine form von qualität ohne
zeit und gibt es nicht vielleicht eine
form von kausalität die rückwärts in die
zeit verläuft also adwords korsischen
das ist eine riesen debatte aber die
wollen wir jetzt mal nicht thematisieren
es gibt also erst mal die zeit und damit
es die zeit würde ich mal sagen es
logisch unabhängig von kausalität
wir können uns zeitliches denken obwohl
die frage ist muss sich in der zeit
wirklich etwas verändern
aber ich denke ich würde mal sagen ja
ich denke schon auch nach kant dass ich
zeit denken lässt ohne kausalität und
zwar deswegen würde ich sagen weil war
wenn wir nach kant arithmetik betreiben
also in der rhein an chance von derzeit
operieren dann spielt dort wenn ich mich
nicht irre die kategorie der kausalität
keine rolle wenn wir mathematische
operationen vornehmen dann verursachen
wir nicht in dem sinne wie wir etwas
ursachen werden wir etwas auf tisch
machen
deswegen würde ich sagen nach meiner
jetzigen zeugung das also kausalität
zeit voraus setzt aber nicht zeit
qualität also dass kausalität irgendwie
nachgeordnet ist logisch lösen sind
jetzt haben sich mehr weg meldet sie
zunächst war das denn wenn du ganz
hinten oder ok dann hier
[Musik]
nie würde ich nicht sagen nehmen sondern
zeit ist eine reine anschauungs formen
die einfach so als eine rahmenbedingung
mal immer schon vorausgesetzt wird
[Musik]
ja aber
also zum beispiel ist es so dass das
jetzt leiden jetzt sagen würde in
leibnitz ich gebe ja noch ein seminar
über was ist zeit immer dienstags und
jetzt hat mir der letzten sitzung noch
mal mit uns mit leibniz befassten
leibnitz akt wenn ich ihn recht verstehe
zeit existiert überhaupt nur durch die
ordnung von dingen durch die bewegung
also sagen wir die bewegung ist derzeit
vor geordert also erkennen zumindest nur
dann die zeit wenn eine ordnung von
dingen vorhanden ist wenn sie da
irgendwas tun und das würde kant das ist
ein system ist asse du kannst sagen okay
kann gut sein aber unter logisch gesehen
eine transzendentale logisch muss noch
bei kann sagen würde das nicht daraus
folgen also verkannt ist die zeit
einfach eine form die eine reine anfangs
form die immer schon im spiel ist und
zwar in der überhaupt erst bewegung und
veränderung stattfinden kann
deswegen würde ich nicht sagen dass die
zeit von der bewegung abhängt oder von
der wendung abhängt zum andersrum ist
anders und es fällt
[Musik]
der integration zeigen sich allerdings
noch immer 1 aus anderen ländern und
lässt die augen ich weiß wann die zeit
dieser ständige
so kann man die bestimmende finden er
sagte ihm ist es eine reine anschauungs
vor
das ist eine form ja es ist immer die
frage was ist jetzt
[Musik]
ja aber man muss eben davon noch
unterscheiden
die erscheinung und sinneseindrücke und
das ist ja was was jetzt endlich von
außen gegeben
also wir natürlich wir verarbeiten das
dann also wir machen einen sinnes
eindruck aber die zeit würde ich nach
kant erstmal nur als eine reine form
natürlich das innere zins bestimmen aber
noch nicht jetzt etwas mit bewegung oder
veränderungen zu tun hat sein was
bewegung und veränderung erst ermöglicht
im sinne dieser zeitlichen logik jetzt
haben sich aber mehrere gemeldet ist
hier und dann hier
genau das würde jetzt leitet zum
beispiel wieder bestreiten aber erkannt
denke ich auch nicht ja also bleibt es
hat eine ganz komische theorie es bin
auch nicht ganz schlau geworden ist also
wird gesagt also zeit ist nur eine
subjektive vorstellung und zeit tritt
dann auf wenn wir es mit ordnungen zu
tun haben mit ordnungen oder
verhältnissen relation von dingen muss
sich wenn ja was für eine relation meint
er denn wenn er nicht mit zeitlicher
relation meint es ist ja nur so habe ich
mir eben die gedanken gemacht dass es
vielleicht die logische folge sein
könnte verdingen dh dass also leute
sagen würde wir können alles nach einer
logischen folge gliedern wie in diesem
rahmen hier immer weitere logische
gliederung vorne und am ende bleibt gar
keine zeit mehr übrig wir können die
zeit immer weiter nach logischen
verhältnissen analysieren und wenn wir
das oft genug tun bis ins letzte detail
dann entsteht der eindruck das tier zeit
im spiel ist dann erscheint die zeit als
ein pedometer negiert die zeit aus dem
logischen verhältnissen von ereignissen
aber die frage ist nicht ob man sich
verschiedene ereignisse in ihrem
verhältnis auch nicht zeitlich denken
kann ob das logische verhältnis von
ereignissen der zeitlichen abfolge
vorausgehen sie noch gerade dazu
den englischen worten diesen prozess
ergibt sich zeitig
hier haben so könnte so so in dieser art
denke dass ich es wahrscheinlich aber
ich mir ist eben nicht klar wie wir aus
logischen beziehung dann die ausdehnung
der zeit bekommen bei logische relation
er nicht ausgedehnt sind also sie sind
schon ein bisschen ausgedehnt würde ich
sage jetzt eine spannende frage in
cannes logik wenn wir jetzt zum beispiel
mathematischen beweis anstrengen
mathematischen beweis
der kürzeste beweis gibt ja diese kann
er bestimmt beweisen dass den kulissen
beweis gibt frag ich das wieder beweisen
muss aber wenn ich das jetzt man sage
dass der kürzeste oder bei einem
schachspiel der kürze zug zum schachmatt
das kann nicht beweisen was der kürzte
zug ist es keine apriori zeigen und dann
könnte man sei erst muss dieser schritt
gemacht werden dann diese dann diese
dann dieser genauso meine beweis auch
ist dieser dann diese dann diese und das
wäre eine gewisse logik norden aber
daraus folgt natürlich noch nicht dass
dies irgendeine ausdehnung hat die
logische und die logische ordnung ist so
dass eine ereignisse was auch immer ein
zug nach dem anderen folgen muss und
zwar auf diese weise aber damit ist eben
noch keineswegs eine zeitliche
ausdehnung impliziert wir erreichen die
zeitliche ausdehnung eigentlich nicht da
muss noch was hinzu kommen und deswegen
gesagt kann müssen wir eben hier wieder
ran zentrale bedingung der möglichkeit
seine reihe anspruchsvolle zeit von
aussetzen es hatte aber sie sich jetzt
und dann ziehen
und die geben sich neben den man sich
als sicher wir sind das ergebnis
unsere das ganze zeit
dass die in abständen zueinander
bekommen dafür sicher
genau wobei man also ich denke auch und
zwar deswegen weil kann tja
metaphorischen eine form spricht eine
form die ein inhalt haben kann aber
nicht umlegen muss jedenfalls eine form
die aufgrund der form des form
charakters vorgeordnet ist irgendwelche
inhalten hier ist die form und dann der
inhalt
ich kann nicht so inhalt ohne die form
haben das verfliest ich muss ich muss
die form schon voraussetzen
darauf können wir dann noch ein bisschen
mehr eine vielleicht im nächsten sitzung
jetzt hatten sie sich noch gemeldet
bei der zwei bekannten diskutieren ob
man die zeit eine dimension
ich brauche die relevant ist für
magische weise das sind ja auch die die
vorstellung dass jemanden auf einen
schlag mit einem klaren zusammenhang
sind auch dann nicht zehn schritte zu
machen in welchen mathematisches problem
habe
natürlich würde ich gerne zeit brauchen
wenn ich zwischen schnitte machen weder
spd noch die möglichkeit
ich habe ein problem unserer keine
statischen mit klage aus zusammen
deshalb weiß ich auch was er da sagt er
der zeit
die politik die un ist wenig 23
das ist man muss natürlich immer das
auch von dem empirischen fall
unterscheiden und natürlich könnte man
jetzt ein hirnforscher hirnforscherin da
auf uns ansetzen und so unsere zeigen
dass selbst wenn es uns vorkommt dass
wir auf einen schlag drei sprünge über
stadtteil schritte gesprungen haben
das ist uns nur so vorkommen dass unser
gehirn aber tatsächlich diese drei
schritte eben ganz schnell
hintereinander getan hat vielleicht kann
natürlich auch sein ich sehe etwas in
dem so sei in einem zusammenhang der
massive ist dass ich etwas nicht so sehe
sondern so etwas einfach so sehr genau
das ist einfach in der ordnung ich habe
es vor mir wie drei dinge nebeneinander
ich sehe es ja holistisch ja ja das ist
das ist möglich genau also so das wäre
auch eine möglichkeit solche und das ist
bestimmt auch bei schachspielerin und
schachspieler so dass die nicht
sukzessive denken sondern dass die
holistische gedenken hier habe ich so
ein muster der muster erkennen
also hier ist die situation intuitiv
wissen
ok jetzt in drei sprüngen drei züge mit
dem springer bin ich da und dann macht
er das so die die haben sowas intuitiv
ist sicherlich
inzwischen nehmen
visionen des tricks für die seite steht
und sie ist es zur tradition der abfall
in platons symposion oder die erkenntnis
schritte in seitlichem nacheinander
existiert in der 61
in den mystischen auch nicht die zeit an
wenn man die dinge in der zusammenschau
also ich ja also wenn jetzt mit bezug
auf diesen logischen verhältnisse kann
man sicherlich sagen dass es bei einer
logik nicht so sehr um die zeit gibt
deswegen wollte ich ja auch die logik
eigentlich als beispiel anführen um zu
zeigen dass es nicht zeitig sein muss
weil er meinen sinn also dann sagen kann
so ein loch ist und mathematischen
beweis der hat verschiedene schritte
oder verschiedene kommt verschiedene
konstellationen verordnungen die
natürlich in sich gerichtet sind
ich kann bei einem logischen beweis
sicherlich manche schritt überspringen
oder manche dinge zugleich sehen genau
genau es gibt mir genau das meine ich
damit und natürlich widerspricht das
nicht ihrer auffassung dass man jetzt
sagen kann ich überspringe jetzt mal
drei natürlich indem ich sie zugleich
sehe aber dann muss ich eben den zehnten
schritt also es geht sind empirische
frage aber es wird wohl niemanden geben
der sehr komplexen beweisen sofort zieht
wäre aber theoretisch möglich also man
kann sich vielleicht ein intelligentes
wesen vorstellen was die ganzen schritte
vor sich sieht in der sukzession aber
eben in dieser in summe also dass sie
neben dann das sehen so wie ich drei
finger sehe drei finger und die sehe ich
nicht 123 zähle ich nicht absolut ich
sehe dass der mensch kann glaube ich
sieben oder zehn sachen als präsent
sehen ohne sie zählen zu müssen
5 auf jeden fall und drei natürlich auch
in zwar natürlich auch dass man das so
sagt das ist eben ein hoch und ein
besonderes intelligentes wesen eben die
1500 zwischen mitglieder logischen
zwischen kinder die eben den beweis
konstituieren sofort vor sich sieht das
müsste möglich sein
aber da wäre natürlich dann immer noch
trotz allem eine gewisse bewegung slow
geteilten das wesen würde auch noch
sehen dass eben der dritte schritt auf
den zweiten folgen muss auch wenn es sie
neben dann das sieht es würde die gehen
dann eben nebeneinander in seiner reihe
sehen
in seiner reihe es würde sehen dass
etwas links ist und etwas rechts ist und
das wäre dann diese logik und die müsste
eben überhaupt nicht zeitlich sein und
deswegen ich glaube dass es sich so
leibnitz vorstellt man sich jetzt aber
eben fragen kann wo dann die ausdehnung
der zeit wieder endspiel kommen die ist
die kann man irgendwie scheint mir
jedenfalls nicht aus einer bloßen
logischen abfolge reduzieren ja und
dieses examen ist es wäre eben dann
vielleicht seien besonders genialer
mathematiker wir besonders geniale
mathematikerin die eben solche dinge
sofort zieht und das müsste
müssen sie gar nicht viel zu tun haben
es gibt eben menschen die in manchen
bereichen so gut sind vielleicht eine
begabung haben dann kommt vielleicht die
mystik wieder ein das ist die frage
eindämmen aber das kann man auch mit
viel übung machen und besonders gute
musikerin musiker die er kennen eben
etwas sofort wenn sie es häufig gemacht
haben da muss man einfach nur häufig
genug üben und eine gewisse grund
begabung mitbringen aber prinzipiell
würde ich das jedem endlich vernünftigen
wesen zumuten
dann setzt man sich beweisen den
branchen
die großeltern hätten die vorstellung
dass situationen intuition
richtig aber die intuition wäre
natürlich streng genommen kein teil des
beweis sei es wäre es wäre er gemäss
wäre so eine muss nicht psychologisch
sein es wäre also eine strategie wäre
der strategie wie man eben zu beweisen
kommt und wie man sich möglichen
ergebnissen annähert aber wenn man den
beweisen eben hin schreibt dann spielt
eben der die genese dass man erst was
mal vermutet hatte oder intuitiv
postuliert hatte dann keine rolle mehr
das geht an den beweis nicht rein
zum beweis abstrahiert von solchen
mechanismen oder strategien der
erfindung
die anderen sind diese überlegung
also man würde vielleicht was finden in
der dritten kritik in der tritt in der
kritik der urteilskraft also der
reflektierenden urteilskraft wo kann
theben von davon spricht dass unsere
vermögen in einem besonders harmonischen
verhältnis zueinander stehen
und da könnte man mal ein bisschen
genauer nachschauen ob da auch eine
andere zeit erfahrung mit dem spiel ist
als im schönen sa kannte harmonieren
einfach alle unsere vermögen
sinnlichkeit verstand begriff anschauung
das passt alles zusammen
und das könnte man versuchen mal so zu
beschreiben dass da auch zeitliche
abfolge keine rolle spielten der
ästhetischen erfahrung
ich würde man ja auch sagen der
ästhetische erfahrung dass man etwas als
schön erkennt das hat nichts mit der
zeit zu tun
das ist also also sozusagen im schönen
haben wir wie bei seinen beweis da haben
einfach der sonne wohl gefügt heid von
relationen die ich auf einen blick
und da spielt jetzt die zeitliche
abfolge ob ich jetzt bei dem bild ist
den kopf dieses porträts anschauen und
dann den fuß kein rolle ist und ich sehe
mit einem blick das ist eine
wohlproportionierte bild wurde die
statue stellen sich die statue vor
die sehen es mit einem blick die statue
ist wie wohl geformt und dann muss ich
erst den fuß anschauen oder den oberarm
oder sowas sind dass sich sofort als es
einfach die solistische waren und das
könnte man durchaus in seiner weise nach
kannten schreiben das ist eine zeitlose
erfahrung ist das ist nicht so dass ich
mir eben erst ein teil anschauen und an
anderen teil sondern dass ich eben
sofort c in der ästhetischen erfahrung
wäre das möglich
sprechen kann ich meinem haus sehen nach
italien muss also dass die reihenfolge
index gibt um eine antwort gehabt er hat
mich aus aber gegen so ein direktes
kommt das ist bei ereignissen eine rolle
spielt indes wegen
wie genau es zum beispiel ist das jetzt
hier dieser diese zitaten und lasst uns
lasst uns zur aufgabe
fortgehen dass etwas geschehe das heißt
etwas oder ein zustand werden der vorher
nicht wahr kann nicht empirisch
wahrgenommen werden wo nicht eine
erscheinung vorher geht welche diesen
zustand nicht in sich enthält in eine
wirklichkeit die auf eine leere
zeitfolge mithin einen stehen vor dem
kein zustand der dinge vorher gedacht
hergeht kann ebenso wenig als die lehre
zeit selbst ab rentiert wird hier kommen
wir zu der lehre zeit ins spiel hat die
kann nicht abmontiert werden
jede aktion eine begebenheit ist als
eine warnung wenn ich auf eine andere
folgt weil dieses aber bei aller synthes
ist aggression so beschaffen ist wie ich
oben an der erscheinung eines hauses
gezeigt habe damit unterscheidet sie
sich dadurch noch von nicht von anderen
allein ich bin merke auch dass wenn ich
an eine erscheinung welch ein geschenk
hält den vorher gegen den zustand der
waren immer nah den folgen aber bienen
das bafa in der prävention erfolgen die
warnung aber auf bin nicht folgen sie
nur vorher gehen kann
das ist dieses beispiel mit dem haus ich
schaue mal ob es noch mal ein bisschen
weil davor war
genauso ist es so ein haus ist sozusagen
nichts was jetzt und in der wahrnehmung
als kausal gegeben ist ein bestand ein
fixes objekt zu zwar das kann ich aus
jeder beliebigen richtung betrachten ich
kann es mir unten nach oben betrachtet
von oben nach unten betrachten da ist
sagen die abfolge der wahrnehmung
irrelevant während ich bei kausalen
verhältnisse neben dabei während bei
kausalen verhältnissen die abfolge der
warnung sehr wohl entscheiden was
ursache und wirkung anbelangt und jetzt
sagt er hier ein bisschen weiter davor
das ist jetzt auf b 234 das nächste zeit
der begriff arbeite eine notwendigkeit
der synthetischen einheit bei sich führt
kann nur ein reiner verstandes begriff
sein denn nicht in der wahrnehmung liegt
und das ist hier der begriff des
verhältnisses von ursachen wirkungen
wovon die erstere also die ursache
die letztere in der zeit als die folge
und nicht als etwas platz bloß in der
einbildung vorher gehen oder gar überall
nicht wahrgenommen sein könnte bestimmt
also ist nur dadurch dass wir die folge
der erscheinungen mit ihnen alle
veränderungen dem gesetze der kausalität
unterwerfen
selbsterfahrung das heißt empirisches
erkenntnis von denselben möglich mithin
sind sie selbst als gegen schilder
erfahrung nur nach eben dem gesetz
möglich wenn jetzt hier von möglich
spricht und von könnte also hier möglich
und könnte
und hier noch einmal möglich das sehen
sie diese ganzen redeweisen ermöglicht
das ist die transzendentale philosophie
das ist wieder diese rahmens geschichte
was muss vorausgesetzt werden was muss
angenommen werden damit ich so etwas
haben kann die erfahrung von kausalität
und hier ist natürlich ganz klar in
bezug auf der video das ist praktisch
sagt des zentralstaates aus und zum
ganzen was unsere ganze passagen der
begriff aber der eine notwendigkeit der
synthetischen einheit danzig führt also
die notwendigkeit ein urteil das ima die
ursache von b ist und zwar notwendig
dieser begriff der notwendigkeit der
kann nur eine reine verstandes begriff
sein wieder sonne
das ist diese rahmen hier apriori nichts
was in der erfahrung liegt was die
erfahrung des möglich macht nur ein
reiner verstandes begriff sein der nicht
in der erfahrung liegt das sagte auch
der video die kausalität die
notwendigkeit nehmen wir nicht wahr
die bringen wir mit dem spiel nur sagte
ich um die bringen wir eben und durch
unsere gewöhnung durch unsere erfahrung
oder unsere ja unsere unseren glauben
mit dem spiel
und dann würde natürlich kann sagen ja
das ist vielleicht richtig aber wenn du
so redest das ist glaube dass eine
subjektive nötigung dann bekommst du
damit niemals die objektive erfahrung
der wirklichkeit hin wenn wir etwas
objektiv wahrnehmen wollen müssen wir
voraussetzen dass es nicht auf ein
subjektives vermögen wie unser glaube
oder sowas zurückzuführen ist sind das
eben das was nur was was verstand des
mäßiges ist was dadurch eben seine
interaktivität behandeln kann also
sondern ganz kurz noch mal gesagt kann
hier gegen jung ergibt erst mit dem er
gibt ihm recht
die notwendige verknüpfung von
ereignissen ist nichts was wir in der
wahrnehmung finden
mit ebenso noch es muss also etwas mit
uns zu tun haben mit dem was wir
mitbringen aber gegen jung es ist nicht
unser glaube ist nicht unsere gewohnheit
die unseren wahrscheinlichkeit sondern
es ist etwas was mit dem verstand zu tun
hat ein verstandes begriff und der ist a
priori und der ist wieder so eine
bedingung der möglichkeit von erfahrung
also wieder so eine rahmung innerhalb
deren sich dann die letzten punkte von
gegebenen befinden
ständig steht ja nicht nur möglich
sondern steht
was bedeutet das geht als unglücklich
das ist notwendig und geboten nur das
ist möglich
das ist auch die beiden einstellen das
ist
und nur so genau
genau guter punkt als er wird es geht
nur noch nicht ganz sicher als er wird
er will natürlich notwendigkeit erklären
er würde sagen so ließ ihnen jetzt
jedenfalls es geht nur mit solchen
voraussetzungen also es geht nur mit
dieser schachtel um hier mit dieser
schachteln und nicht mit einer hand aber
da müsste man fragen er ist sind aber
überhaupt diese schachtel ung vorhanden
also dass das könnte man noch zu
rückfragen oder also ich mein okay nur
mit dieser schachtel und geht nur mit
dieser schafft ist es möglich aber gibt
es diese schachtel dass die frage ob wir
eben tatsächliche kausalität erfahrung
machen das müsste ja noch eine weitere
prämisse sein
es gibt erfahrungen von kausalität wir
haben diese erfahrung und nur mit dieser
einstellung können wir sie erklären
dann würde daraus irgendwie folgen dass
das notwendig ist sozusagen als ist es
notwendig vorauszusetzen das auch nicht
fragen ist es notwendig so was diese
rahmen vorauszusetzen
oder ist diese rahmung notwendig also
notwendig existent notwendig da ja
franz und ich werden vom kunden sind
gelegen hatte und den rhein zeitung
das st
ja aber haben doch kann würde das eben
schon sagen wollen wie es draußen ist
natürlich nicht bei den dingen an sich
aber er möchte eben tatsächlich
objektivität begründen ich glaube er
möchte es noch
glaube ich nicht als ich glaube deswegen
spricht ja auch nicht von menschen sind
er spricht von dort vernünftigen wesen
und da spielt also die gehirnstruktur
keine rolle ist dann eben einfach ein
vermögen der rationalität wie auch immer
das jetzt realisiert ist neuronal
interessiert ihn auch nicht das
interessiert dann einfach diese reihe
vorne und ich lese ihnen also noch ein
bisschen stärker es gibt verschiedene
lesarten von kann
es gibt eine schwächere als in dem sinne
dass man konstruktive ist oder es ist
halt eine der aussagen über die unsere
erkenntnismöglichkeiten sagt ich lese
ein bisschen stärker ich glaube er will
damit sagen nur so können wir überhaupt
objektiv erkenntnis machen und erkennt
dass es objektiv also was er zeigen
möchte jetzt tatsächlich so wie es
wirklich ist und zwar wirklichkeit
bekommt nach kant neuen sinn das muss
man auch dazusagen wirklichkeit ist
nicht das ding an sich ist eine
wirklichkeit ist die inter subjektiv
verbindliche aussage über die
zusammenhänge von ereignissen
wirklichkeit
ein anderes lesen dahin überreicht
ja also da gibt es verschiedene kits
verschiedene der band aber ich lese ich
ein bisschen stärker also dass er eben
wirklich sagt auch ein sondern so ein
allmächtiges wesen hat ja auch diese
theorien würde sicherlich jetzt nicht in
der zeit existieren aber die
verbindlichkeit denke ich will doch
überall gegeben aber das ist eine
spannende frage haben wir noch meldungen
dazu erst nachsehen
[Musik]
ja es gibt eben bei kann dann eben noch
dieser man muss dazu sagen es gibt bei
kant eben noch diese zweistelligkeit
lehre von erkenntnis also erkenntnis ist
nach kant anschauen und begriff wir
haben eben immer ein letztes moment von
sinneswahrnehmung und das ist dieses
letzte iks weil sich daran gezeigt hat
das muss immer auch noch gegeben sein
auch wenn es bei kant manchmal den
anschein hat dass diese six am ende doch
logisch aufgelöst wird
jetzt hat mir noch zwei meldungen erst
hier und hier
letztlich richtig
das ist ein guter punkt also man kann
jetzt von kant so sprechen dass er eine
transzendentale und theologie machen
keine und logie im klassischen sinne wie
sie aristoteles gemacht hatte da gibt es
ein ding das und das sein kann versucht
und theologie immer durch rückgriff auf
die erkennende subjektivität zu
begründen das ist das spannende frage ob
kann tatsächlich trans zentrale
ontologie entwickelt markus gabriel den
sie erwähnten der selbst vertretene
trans zentrale ontologie transzendentale
und tobias ontologie das was es gibt
gibt es nur in sinn feldern und sinn
felder sind letztendlich abhängig von
dem erkennenden subjekt ohne dadurch
relativ zu werden wir können objektiv
über dinge reden nur würde eher sagen
die rede von dingen von objekten ist
unabhängig von erkennen den subjekten
sinnlos also die rede von dingen von der
welt macht gar keinen sinn wenn wir
nicht erkennen dass objekte voraussetzen
spannende these
würde auch gern zugeben würde er auch
zugeben dass kante einer ein paar tipps
stand hat natürlich kommt da noch
wittgenstein andere ins spiel
wir haben jetzt hier schon einige
wichtige zentrale zitat gelesen aber
bislang nicht durchgekommen
deswegen werden wir die nächste sitzung
auch noch mal dazu darauf verwenden
diese zitate zu lesen ich glaube ich
habe ihn ja ungeschickt gehabt auf
diesem ausdruck ich schicke ihnen aber
auch noch einmal die folien herum dass
wir uns dann direkt auf diese
textpassagen in der nächsten sitzung
beziehen können dann bis in einer woche